well what are y'all doing
it's impossible to measure the joy
leslie jordan brought to 2020.
i feel like y'all all out there screwing
and
here i am to sit and
whale screw on oh my gosh i'm the only
person that just
used the pandemic to go to new heights
i just started doing funny things on
instagram
and 5.5 million
followers the 65 year old actor went
viral by posting short instagram videos
of himself at home
during quarantine honey i conquered
netflix
i've watched them all and i watched the
one about ivan the terrible there is
nothing left whether he is dancing
[Music]
having pillow talk feel a talk now this
is a secret story you can't tell anybody
or just venting about isolation i'm
talking
to my friends mama quit bothering me
how much more this can i take leslie is
lighting up our lives just by being
himself
the beauty of my exercise regime
is it oh sweet tea i love it is it
allows you to eat
whatever you want i was being silly and
i
i thought all my friends have done
exercise videos you know with these flat
abs i thought i'm gonna do one
and i got a back scratcher and i made it
into a
a routine like a baton
and that i think that was the one i have
come up with a better exercise today
than yesterday
yesterday we used the back scratcher to
great effect
today we're going to make the back
stretcher a baton
let's not forget he has had an
incredible 30-year acting career
including his notable roles on american
horror story and
will and grace i am so sorry i missed
the ceremony
but tell me this darling do they still
say till death do us part when the bride
is a vampire
and back in the 90s leslie even worked
with george clooney
she knew what it would say he had
written to her before fast forward to
2020 and leslie jordan has emerged
the king of quarantine the bag boys
they don't like running out go dude
bro you're the dude from the internet
my friend actually called and said you
should do a yoga one i saw no yogi's so
i got down on the floor and was gonna do
what my friend thought would be funny
and it was filthy
and so i posted that i don't want to be
up in my mind
it's like a bad neighborhood honey you
do not want to be up there alone
the beloved actor's instagram posts have
celebs all over his comments
michelle pfeiffer comments on every
single one of your
videos who is the person that like
reached out to you the the celebrity
that kind of blew your mind when they
heard her
yeah she came because she invited me
over to her house i thought oh i can't
go over your hands wait wait you gotta
go
but out of all those stars there is one
southern bell that sticks out
there is no dolly parton it's been me
all these years
in drag the proof have you ever seen
dolly nine in the same room
who would be your dream quarantine
partner leslie
dolly parton a
thing to us dolly why dolly
because she's from um real near me
where i grew up and when i hear her
talk it's home it's going to be like
leslie's
bucket list i just want to make dolly
parton
i can't go under the raisins i'll cry
his dreams came true because he finally
got to meet
dolly in person everybody loves dolly
leslie is grateful for how much his life
has changed but did admit that it could
be a little overwhelming
oh it's exhausting being
viral i've gone viral
i'm 65. do you mind if i take a nap